this program is brought to you by Emory
University
so tell me about social medicine why
it's important here social medicine
center project I'm really excited to be
involved with we're starting to teach
medical students and residents more
about the care of patients outside of
the existing so one thing you really
focus on in medical school you learn how
to diagnose something how to figure out
what's going on to the patient and what
are the treatment plans to put in place
for that patient the other side of that
is how are we getting the patients to
afford the medications are we making
sure that they're taking their
medications once they leave the clinic
visit a lot of the times we get focused
on what's happening inside of our office
but really when the patient leaves
they're facing a whole different life
outside of your office where high blood
pressure may not be the most important
thing on their list so we have to find a
way to reach our patients we think about
things that cultural competency health
care disparities global health patient
advocacy so we're teaching right that is
how to take that next step to really be
an effective position
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University